we know very little for certain about
the life of the Chinese philosopher
Confucius he said to have been born in
551 BC in China he may have been a
student of the Taoist master loud soo
according to tradition he began
government service and served many roles
including minister of crime under duke
ding in the state of Lu
however Confucius in the Duke fell out
after the Duke received a present from a
neighboring ruler 80 beautiful women and
124 horses the Duke spent all his time
riding horses and being entertained by
the women which confucius found deeply
improper for a ruler so he left the
court and wandered for years around
between the 3rd and 5th century BC
Confucius his works were collected into
the Analects a collection of sayings
written down by his followers some of
the morals Confucius taught are easily
recognizable most notably his version of
the Golden Rule do not do unto others
what you don't want done to yourself but
some of them also sound very strange or
old-fashioned to modern ears especially
to western ones but we need his advice
all the more for this it serves as an
antidote to the troubles we currently
face here are a few examples of what
Confucius helps us to remember one
ceremony is important the Analects are
filled with strange conversations
between Confucius and his disciples like
this one saycome wish to do away with
the offering of a sheep Confucius said
say you love the Sheep I loved the
ceremony at first this is baffling if
not also humorous why not save the sheep
but Confucius is reminding say and us
about the importance of ceremony in the
modern world we tend to shun ceremony
and see this as a good thing a sign of
intimacy or a lack of pretension but
Confucius believed in the value of
ceremonies over sheep because he valued
what he called ritual propriety this
might seem a very outdated and
conservative idea but in fact many of us
longed for particular rituals that meal
mum cooked for us whenever we were sick
all the yearly birthday outing or our
wedding vows we understand that certain
premeditated deliberate and precise
gestures stir our emotions deeply
rituals make our intentions clear and
they help us to understand how to behave
too we should treat our parents with
reverence in particular Confucius had a
very strict idea about how we should
behave towards our parents he believed
that we should obey them when we're
young
for them when they're old mourn at
length when they die and make huge
sacrifices in their memory thereafter he
even said that we shouldn't travel far
away while our parents are alive and
should come for them if they steal a
sheep this attitude is known as filial
piety this sounds strange now when many
of us leave our parents home as
teenagers and rarely return to visit we
may even see them as strangers
arbitrarily thrust upon us by fate after
all our parents are so out of touch so
pitifully human in their shortcomings so
difficult so judgemental and have such
bad taste in music
yet Confucius recognized that in many
ways moral life begins in the family we
cannot truly be caring wise grateful and
conscientious unless we remember mums
birthday and meet dad for lunch three we
should be obedient to honourable people
modern society is very egalitarian we
believe that we're all born equal and
should ultimately be able to say and do
whatever we like we reject many rigid
hierarchical roles yet Confucius told
his followers let the ruler be a ruler
the subject a subject a father a father
and a son a son this might sound jarring
but it is in fact important to realize
that there are people worthy of our deep
veneration even our simple and humble
obedience we need to be modest enough to
recognize the people whose experience or
accomplishments outweigh our own we
should also practice peaceably doing
what these people need ask or command
Confucius explained the relation between
superiors and inferiors is like that
between the wind and the grass the grass
must Bend when the wind blows across it
bending gracefully is in fact not a sign
of weakness but a gesture of humility
and respect for cultivated knowledge can
be more important than creativity modern
culture places a lot of emphasis on
creativity unique insights that come to
us suddenly but Confucius was adamant
about the importance of the universal
wisdom that comes from years of hard
work and reflection he listed
benevolence ritual propriety
righteousness wisdom integrity as the
five constant virtues what Confucius
believed that people were inherently
good he also saw that virtues like these
must be constantly cultivated just like
plants in a garden
he spoke about moral character and
wisdom as the work of a lifetime we can
see now why he had such reverence for
his elders of course a burst of
inspiration may well be what we need to
start our business or redo our
draft or reinvent our life but if we're
being very honest with ourselves we'll
have to admit that we also need to
devote more energy to slowly changing
our habits this more than anything else
is what prevents us from becoming truly
intelligent accomplished and wise
Confucius died without reforming the
decadent Duchannes officials but after
his death his followers created schools
and temples in his honor across East
Asia passing his teachings along for
over 2,000 years today millions of
people still follow Confucius his
teachings as a spiritual religious
discipline and his thought has been a
huge influence on Eastern political
ideas about morality obedience and good
leadership we might find Confucian
virtues of its strange or old-fashioned
but this is what ultimately makes them
all the more important we need them as a
corrective to our own excesses the
modern world is almost surprisingly
totally unconformity Galit aryan and
full of innovation so we conversely at
risk of becoming impulsive irreverent
and thoughtless without a little advice
from Confucius about good behavior and
cheap
you